hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys i'm
gerry we're checking out the trailer for
a bill murray bruce willis comedy cone
rock the casbah yeah just like the clash
song i hope they include the song in the
trailer you had me oh they will you had
me at Bill Murray and you kind of look
like I'm not big on Bruce Willis right
now man I don't think anyone is my don't
think Bruce Willis is big on Bruce
Willis yeah like why why you keep
showing up these movies he likes the
money that's why yeah you don't look
like you wanted P there I could see no
he was happen enough money he said in
interviews that he's bored I want to be
the one direct I heard six or do some
crazy [ __ ] with that script it should
take place at like the biggest strip
club and he has to get strippers out of
there alive like a 12-story strip club
yeah the next one's about his nephew who
doesn't want to be in mcclain I am
Richie Lanz it's a real pleasure time
for a crazy story
hi wasn't rock to a ranger and this is
where I'm supposed to call supposed to
tour with my act to Afghanistan
you will play in front of 2,000 horny
soldiers ganar oh I'm sorry I can't tell
if you're vomiting you're laughing it
would really appreciate a junior
executive suite definitely off the
street rise and shine bad girls gone she
stole my wallet my money my passport I'm
royally screwed they've come to lunch
time nice to be here that's what I know
about the hell I doing here Richie Lanz
talent manager are y'all doing guys
assalamualaikum rum at the light butter
cockle back at you babe just got to be
ninja this has gotta be fate I must go
to Kabul I must say okay I'm going on
twenty percent all right back in the
trunk I'm kidding
fire
thank you thank you very much very levis
and directed it I don't like the true
like the trait I feel like there could
be a good movie and I'm not really big
on that as a trailer then yeah I want to
like really obvious I want to be appeal
to it but the jokes kind of sucked a lot
and they weren't funny i mean the the
only really intriguing thing to me about
this is you know like there's something
that's always interesting about Bill
Murray to watch he does seem to be doing
more of a character than just depressed
dry guy you know it's cool to be seeing
that I like when Bruce Willis has a
little bit more fun he's in one shot of
this Jam one shot of this trailer he's
sitting down leaning against a wall like
he might be having fun but it's like a
very relaxed well this is a clearly a
comedy though what just happened in
Bruce was played himself in that movie
and Bruce Willis had a lot of fun with
that and that wasn't that long ago when
I came out it's been like seven years
since I came out so i remember liking
Bruce Willis and that Barry Levinson's a
good director he did you don't know jack
which I really liked for HBO and the
cast is cool too I like zooey deschanel
she's [ __ ] cheating on it feels out
of places she was just disappeared like
I know she's like that she's playing a
musician again of course as she's some
funky she well she is musician my
girlfriend's in the other room right now
this is my impression i keep Dodson
hanging out with ryan right Oh started
choking on my penis no I got that I joke
I figured that out I just think you were
reenacting on scene from identity I like
to respect woman hey man there was no
class song I know we were so has no we
we were so I said I hope you're like
they will yeah I was so wrong hey ryan
reilly fit in this trailer I mean
there's no like a lot of things don't
fit in this true I hope it's a better
movie than it is a trailer it just has
that same type of like foreigners or
strange type of thing and it just trying
to make Afghanistan like a funny
backdrop girl that's every clip that
shows for this trailer was like a good
start clip that needed to be followed up
by like something that took it bigger I
made it more you know interesting and it
was just a bunch of like start out clear
yeah see my concern is this it's a
comedy and comedies tend to do something
that I hate which is they show the best
jokes in the trailer then every once in
a while comedy comes out and you're like
hey the best jokes weren't in the
trailer I'm hoping it's like that for
this movie hopefully I mean this also
seems like the kind of movie that's not
like hello like it seems like context
and and you know the rhythm of scenes
will help the comedy and it's harder to
get that kind of humor out in a trailer
like this what I will say to is that it
takes place in Afghanistan so we could
get a really funny beheading Singh
that's not gonna happen Justin honest
that'd be funny and would ajan Bill
Murray getting beheaded now I don't
mercy got killed in zombieland as a
zombie now Shh the head no I'm not even
gonna pick that one up and dribble it
for him don't like the territory of this
jugs going down no not right anyway guys
thanks for tuning in to the real reject
shove I'm doing the outro if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can check out reasons
to Jerry and dank
stubbs on this channel and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
and vine because if we get into
followers we can get product placement
meaning loads of but asked cash for us
what did you just say and it's like you
open up a closet that was too full of
words and just some words fell don't
block my vocabulary you horny son of a
[ __ ]
Jordan Emma Nettie imminent a imminent a
oh can I get a shout out for being a
longtime subscriber sure Jordan Eminem
take here's your shoutout I am so happy
that you decided to subscribe you know
Jordan and Minh entei him and I used to
go to the local strip club together yeah
that african-american strip clubs he was
really into black chicks and I wasn't
there you do like a mixture of different
ethnicities at most strip clubs no this
one was primarily black tricks you know
like he wanted them was a prostitute you
want to see my impression no I don't a
prostitute at him hanging out of Jordan
melon oh it went like this
no gag reflex is amazing this is a good
job you got lucky